these festivals called fire and water
festivals are two sort of appease the
mountain give celebration and gifts to
the goddess Mount Fuji
so that she will not destroy them okay
then I don't think I need to light this
one actually I think the light would
actually hurt this one so I think I'm
gonna just have her eat it you can have
cookies cakes candies bento boxes coffee
cups tea cups whatever whatever you can
think of that you could put Fuji on
you'll find it
climbing Mount Fuji is a mine exercise
it's it's really mind over matter more
than anything there's a word they used
to call combate which is persevere
persevere is a big word in Japanese
culture and language I think it's good
that it's a misty day because it's
actually been able to cut down on the
the heat and stop gonna take pictures is
a good excuse to take a break so the
original purpose of climbing Mount Fuji
was as a religious pilgrimage
these always kind of amazed an event
when you climb for 12 hours or whatever
any cop you see this gorgeous sunrise it
just really is quite an emotional event